Florida Governor Ron desantis's not yet
even a real campaign campaign might
already be collapsing and I have to tell
you I have very mixed feelings about it
on the one hand I am enjoying the cringe
and the disasters that are plaguing Ron
DeSantis daily because it's just so
entertaining and it really couldn't
happen to a worse guy on the other hand
I also recognize that Trump's a disaster
and desantis's failings are good for
Trump and it's hard to get behind things
that are good for Trump as well but let
me tell you what's been going on amid
flooding in Florida as well as long gas
lines which are currently happening as a
result of the flooding Ron DeSantis has
been out on a non-campaign campaign book
related events and yesterday he was in
South Carolina at an event with his wife
which went so cringe so quick that it's
actually hard to believe let's look at a
couple of clips of this uh Ron appearing
with Casey DeSantis and they tell a very
coordinated story you know DeSantis is
in this war with Disney and Disney World
down in Florida and they tell the story
about how you know they had a Disney
wedding or something but it was all
before they fell in love at Disney but
it was all before Disney went woke and
it only gets worse from there and the
coordinated and scripted nature of this
it's so cringy and he's pulling his wife
into it and the mega donors that were
thinking about backing DeSantis are
already bailing and I'm going to tell
you about that in a moment I'm getting
ahead of myself let's start with this
event
listen to this heartwarming story of
love from the governor one day she comes
to me and says you know she comes to me
with tears in her eyes and she says sir
talking to my parents and and they were
interested in potentially doing the
wedding at Walt Disney World
oh
I I remember when this broke in the news
everybody thought it was so scandalous
like DeSantis got married at Disney like
yeah it was great back then but he had
one caveat though when I because he was
very gracious Casey DeSantis is even
using Trump's mannerisms interestingly
enough now you go do what you want to do
this is your thing go it's wonderful and
we grew up coming from Ohio going to
Disney we had a lot of fun before they
went woke obviously
um but it was one caveat he said you can
do it however
no Mickey Donald Duck anybody at the
wedding ceremony they actually have a
wedding chat it's really nice and um and
everything worked out it was traditional
in fact you look at our wedding pictures
you wouldn't know that it was anything
you were uh no isn't this just a great
story guys anything out of the ordinary
um but you know we're doing that and
then uh thinking about so this was I
mean this is almost 15 years ago and
then we're no one was thinking like that
somehow this would end up being
something we would be involved with you
know you know going Toe to Toe with them
about about gender ideology and
kindergarten are you kidding me I mean
it's just absurd hindergarten that's
interesting but that's just the way life
works well it's so funny because people
would say oh did you ever see you know
that the governor was going to be the
governor I'm like you know when we when
I first met him he was a cute guy in the
Navy like I I fell for the white uniform
right like it was very handsome he was
like Tom just like hold up does she
actually say Tom Cruise I'm right like
it was very handsome he was like Tom
Cruise it was
I was going to jokingly say just like
Tom Tom Cruise in uh top few Top Gun or
whatever A Few Good Men
um this is this is not helping uh
DeSantis that's the really interesting
thing this obsession with Disney I mean
okay cringe-worthy scripted story fine
this is really not helping DeSantis he's
in South Carolina telling Disney stories
while Florida is in chaos due to
flooding and gas lines and meanwhile
when he is in Florida he's just obsessed
with Disney World to such a degree that
even some Republicans Like Larry Kudlow
are saying this really isn't looking
very good he then did like a more formal
event in South Carolina about the
Florida blueprint I guess trying to
portray the idea that South Carolina and
other red States should copy the
blueprint of Florida which quite frankly
is a very very mediocre State you all
know I love going to Florida I go down
to Miami I go to the you know liberal
areas I'm at hipster cafes and all this
stuff but the truth is that if you zoom
out and look at the state in sum total
it's a very mediocre State not
particularly good or bad when it comes
to infrastructure crime education just
like around 25th out of 50 in most
categories why would you follow that as
a blueprint well here he explains part
of the blueprint is you got to get woke
out and transgender and all this stuff
that's driving donors away the people
also side with us on wanting an economy
where businesses focus on their core
mission of providing whatever service or
whatever they're doing in the economy
and not getting mired into woke
political activism and you see it time
and time again sometimes it's a one-off
like this uh ridiculous thing with with
Bud Light by trying to push the
transgenderism but what they're doing is
do you guys think that anybody has been
pushed into transgenderism by seeing or
hearing that Dylan Mulvaney
drank Bud Light and had some kind of a
spot like the the this the very nature
of you can push people into being trans
is one of the oldest tropes it used to
be about you can push people into being
gay now it's you can push people into
being trans these are corporations
mostly very wealthy powerful
corporations they're trying to leverage
their economic power to change our
country all right they're just doing
what's profitable that's really all
that's going on and DeSantis at this
point seeming desperately uh um obsessed
with Disney and with Bud Light and just
one last clip from this totally deranged
event here is Ron Des Sanctus saying
woke seven times in 20 seconds so
because the woke represents a war on
Truth uh we have no other recourse but
to wage a war on woke we fight the woke
in the schools we fight the woke in the
legislature we fight the woke and the
corporations we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob Florida is
where woke goes to die
yeah there you go so this is not a good
idea
DeSantis donors aren't happy with this
and the polling shows as I told you two
weeks ago most people are on the side of
wokeness but let's now talk about the
trouble that Des Sanctus is creating for
himself with this anti-woke Crusade one
of our sponsors is Helix sleep I have
been sleeping on a helix mattress at
home for years now I couldn't be more
happy with it I recommend it to
everybody the other day even though
she's not allowed in the big bed I put
my baby daughter on the mattress and
even she loved it Helix sleep is the
premium mattress brand offering tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences take the Helix sleep quiz it
asks you about your body type your
sleeping position do you get hot at
night do you have back pain and then
Helix will match you with the mattress
that's perfect for you most people don't
know where to begin when shopping for a
mattress including me Helix makes it
simple and less risky because you know
you're getting a match address that fits
your needs it ships free you can try it
for a hundred nights to see if you like
it and it comes with a 10 or 15 year
warranty unlike many mattress companies
all Helix mattresses are made in the USA
by a skilled production team so you are
supporting good jobs Helix sleep is
giving my audience up to 20 percent off
plus two free pillows what other
mattress company is going to give you 20
off go to Helix sleep.com Pacman the
link is down below